>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Anne McLean: Good
evening and welcome.
I'm Anne McLean from the
library's music division.
It's my great pleasure tonight
to welcome Janet Eilber,
artistic director of the Martha
Graham Center for Contemporary Dance
and choreographer and
filmmaker Pontus Lidberg.
Tonight as part of our Martha Graham
at the Library Festival we're
presenting the world premiere
performance of his Woodland
set to a score by Irving Fein,
Fein's Notturno for
Harp and Strings.
Thank you've both for being here.
It's very, very exciting for us.
Today the Washington Post has a
wonderful headline for the Library
of Congress and Martha
Graham the legacy lives on,
exactly on the mark, exactly.
So this is truly an
exciting moment for us.
We mark a long time partnership
with the Martha Graham Dance Company
that began over a half century ago.
It began with the now
historic evening
of three Graham ballets commissioned
by the library's Coolidge
Foundation, Appalachian Spring,
Herodiade and Darius
Milhaud's Imagined Wing.
Through that astonishing
exhilarating collaboration the
library has established a
relationship that has continued
to grow and flourish and your
new work, a joint commission
of the library's Verna
and Irving Fein Fund
and the Martha Graham Center
is a beautiful blossoming
of this tradition.
We look forward to seeing it
and you will be mounting this
in New York very soon, right?
>> Janet Eilber: April 18th
will be its New York premiere
and that is actually the
company's 90th birthday.
Martha Graham had her first
concert with a group of dancers,
a trio of young women,
on April 18 in 1926.
>> Anne McLean: So we really
have a lot to celebrate.
We have 180 years, we're going to be
saying this throughout the evening,
180 years, 90 for you
and 90 for the library
and it's an amazing serendipity so
we'll be talking about our history
with you and about the Martha Graham
collection here at the library
which you were instrumental in
bringing and what that is about
and our shared commitment to
supporting new work plus a preview
of Pontus' new piece and
maybe a quick glance at some
of the impressive new ventures
from the Graham Company
like their new forthcoming
YouTube channel.
So let's talk about how this
developed, how we got to be able
to be so fortunate as
to have this new piece.
This was a discussion that took
place over three or four years
with Janet and LaRue Allen and we
were very, very excited and hopeful
when we knew you were
going to be involved
and this I know is a huge
part of your forward path
for the Graham Company's new work.
I wanted to ask you Pontus
what was the experience
like of working with
the Graham Company?
>> Pontus Lidberg: So
the Graham dancers just
like ballet dancers have
a very strong foundation
but it's not ballet it's different.
They are trained equally
specifically and clearly
but in a different way and
I'm rather used to working
with ballet dancers
and these dancers came
with definitely equal amounts
of physicality and clarity
in their movement but coming
from a different place
which has informed me as
a choreographer as well
and it has definitely
informed the work.
>> Anne McLean: And you studied this
technique at some point yourself.
>> Pontus Lidberg: Yes, well so
I was a trained ballet dancer
but as part of my education
was various forms
of contemporary dance movement and
Graham technique was the first one
that I was exposed to but I think
in general Graham was one of the few
who really codified a technique.
Other choreographers have a
lineage or a style of training
but she actually codified
a technique
but most contemporary
training is not
like that, it's much more nebulous.
>> Anne McLean: And you've also
commented on the expressivity
of this particular troupe,
their facial expressions
and the whole aesthetic.
>> Pontus Lidberg: This is also
something I very much appreciate
because the company, the
dancers have a strong confidence
in their facial expression.
There are certain movements
of contemporary dance
where the face is kind
of forgotten on purpose
where the movement is supposed
to speak and you're not supposed
to emote with your face but these
dancers' faces are very alive
and I find that very
inspiring and true to people.
>> Anne McLean: And that's
something that you studied,
I mean I know it's a
10-year process, right?
The Graham technique, I think.
>> Janet Eilber: That's what Martha
used to say that it takes 10 years
to make a dancer but I think what
Pontus is describing is just the
element of the Graham
technique which is
that she created this vocabulary
sort of born out of body language,
out of natural gesture,
because she wanted
to describe what she called the
inner landscape, the human emotions
and conditions rather than
swans and flowers and kings
and queens she was going for
what was really going on here
in the late 1920s and 30s
and the vocabulary she developed
is a combination of the core,
emotion riding on the breath and
coming from the core of the body
and her famous contraction and
release which is the energizing
of the torso and it is a perfect
marriage between that physicality,
the physical vocabulary, and
the emotion that it's describing
so for Graham dancers
they are really trained
to illuminate the physical movement
with an emotional image
in the classroom.
It's a marriage between the two.
You will see in Medea tonight
and Appalachian Spring the
dancers really have to be actors
as well as incredible athletes.
>> Anne McLean: And even
just in their carriage,
I mean anyone who has seen a Graham
performance the way they step
onto the stage is like actors
in a [inaudible] theater
or anything else, immediate
presence and charisma.
That's something I took away with me
from the first time I
saw a Graham performance.
Thinking about the music watching
your work there's such musicality
and I know you are a musician
first, what was your instrument
and what made you choose
the path to dance?
>> Pontus Lidberg: I was trained as
a pianist as a young boy and it was
as I remember, and
I was pretty young
so I might not remember everything,
but at 10 you kind of have
to choose professional training for
both music or dance and I auditioned
for both professional schools
that were available in Stockholm
and I was accepted into both so I
had to make a choice then and there
and the one thing I
remember is that the audition
for the music classes were on a
Sunday in the winter and I was alone
with the teacher in a
room and I was singing
and I guess they were just
testing me and the audition
for the ballet school was on a
Thursday night and it was full
of people in the corridors
and in their classrooms
and on stage training
and running past
and it felt like a dynamic place.
I honestly think that that was
a deciding factor [laughter].
>> Anne McLean: Interesting.
>> Pontus Lidberg: And to add
to that I know many musicians
and they have a wonderful rich
life and also solace especially,
a rather lonesome life sitting
by themselves practicing.
>> Anne McLean: Yes, or in a hotel
room touring constantly, it's true.
Thinking about the music for your
work, Irving Fein's lyrical Notturno
for Harp and Strings it's very
interesting for us to see this work,
people who know the work as a
chamber piece, to see it come
into a new dimension through
your dance and this reminded me
of Janet's phrase seeing the
classics through new eyes
and I was wanting to,
I was thinking too
about how you re-envisioned
the classic ballet Raymonda.
Would you like to talk
a little bit about that?
>> Pontus Lidberg: So
Raymonda is a work I made
for the Royal Swedish
Ballet about one
and a half years ago was the
premier and it's a classical ballet,
one of the classics
by Glazunov but not
that often performed
actually and it's huge.
It's very long and very big
work and I reinvented it
by writing a new libretto because
the libretto has a lot of problems
for our contemporary times.
It's very racist and it's also
kind of all over the place.
It's one of those librettos
where you think,
I mean I don't exactly know but I'm
pretty sure that it was written more
to be able to showcase we want
this kind of Oriental dance here
and then we want this there,
kind of like wrote their
libretto haphazardly
to suit various inspirations.
But I completely rewrote it
while keeping certain elements
and it was kind of coming full
circle for me because I was trained
in ballet but I very early
chose to go a contemporary path.
I felt like there was more
to do in contemporary dance
and definitely more to
explore but that training just
like Graham training is
something you just can't undo.
I mean it's in my body
so it was interesting
to come full circle
and revisit that again.
>> Anne McLean: In the
piece with the music,
with the Fein piece you
actually reordered it slightly
and made it cyclical I
think you read about -
>> Pontus Lidberg: So that I did
with Raymonda too by the way.
I reordered it to suit the
new libretto but with this
with the Notturno for Harp and
Strings I thought that I didn't want
to illustrate the work
only but I wanted
to somehow add a new structure
to it and so I added a repeat.
I framed the work with a
fast section, the animato,
and then I reordered the two
slow sections and it kind
of almost became a
mirror or a cycle both.
It kind of goes to the middle
and then it almost rewinds
but takes a different path back and
I found that that was interesting
because it also talks to Irving Fein
which I can't do but
I can add a comment.
>> Anne McLean: It was so nice to
see in the film about your work
and about this project which you
can see in our lobby here tonight.
It's so nice to see the
pictures of the composers
that to the Graham Company has
worked with including now this music
from Irving Fein but you I guess
you found in your archives some
of those photos to bring out
and music has always been
a hugely important part
of what you do choosing
the music and so on.
For us it's exciting tonight
to have a live orchestra.
We try every time to
have a live orchestra
when we can possibly do it
and it sounds fantastic.
It's a little challenging and we'll
get to the challenges of working
in the Coolidge in just
a minute [laugher].
Regarding your work as a filmmaker
I wanted to ask you to touch on that
and ask you about how it affects
your vision for your choreography.
>> Pontus Linberg: It's a
question I get fairly often.
The first thing I would
say is that when I create
for film the option I have
which I don't have on stage is
to completely direct
the eye of the audience.
I can zoom in on a
button for example
and that is what everyone will see
in film but when you put something
on stage you can't do
that, in fact you leave it
to each individual audience member
to follow their own path so you have
to think differently about structure
and there are very different
ways of working actually.
>> Anne McLean: I was
wondering I was thinking
about Martha Graham's experiments
in technique and her inspiration
from the visual arts
and her statement
on seeing a Kandinsky painting
in 1926 before she
had even become known
as a choreographer in New York.
She looked at the painting
and her response later was
I will dance like that.
It's just an extraordinary
comment and I wanted to see Janet
if you had thoughts on the
visual arts in later Graham works
and today too how you
are working with visuals.
>> Janet Eilber: Well Martha
drew great inspiration
from such a variety of things.
She was a voracious
reader, she loved poetry.
When she saw the Kandinsky in '26
or I thought it was '23 she
was visiting the first exhibit
in America at the Chicago
Art Institute
of the European abstract
painters, modern painters,
and she said she was relieved to
see the exhibit because she was
so relieved to see that there were
other people who thought the way
that she did to see
this abstract work
and the Kandinsky had
a streak of red in it.
She said she would make a dance like
that and that's our dance Diversion
of Angels from 1948 which is
unfortunately not in this program
but when she was choreographing
she would bring
in huge coffee table art books with
specific paintings or sculptures
or sometimes natural
things, leaves and trees
that she was drawing inspiration
from on whatever new work
that she was creating
and it was just one
of the many ways she filled herself
with inspiration before
she started to choreograph.
>> Anne McLean: And she
was also very much involved
in union psychology
studying that as well, right?
Joseph Campbell and -
>> Janet Eilber: Joseph Campbell
was married to one of the members
of her company, Jean Erdman,
yes, so that was in the '40s.
Erick Hawkins who Martha married
for a short time had studied the
classics at Harvard and we think
that is why the Greek period
appeared and Erick was inspiring her
and after she divorced Erick she
was [inaudible] analysis [laughter]
so she was kind of drawing
inspiration from all over the place
but the Dark Meadow suite on
tonight's program is a suite
of highlights from the much
longer work, Dark Meadow,
and Dark Meadow is considered
to be her [inaudible] piece
created while she was in analysis
about life's greatest
adventure, I'll quote it tonight
in our introduction,
the adventure of seeking
so it's a ballet about questioning.
There's no dramatic narrative,
it's about life's journey.
>> Anne McLean: And
this is something,
these areas that we're talking
about the psyche and myth of poesis
and so forth, these are very
much in the line of thinking
of Isamu Noguchi and as many of you
in the room know we've had the
pleasure of having an exploration
of the connection between Graham
and Noguchi in the past week.
It's been really exciting and fun,
something very different for us,
but I was thinking back to the
art again how she took Noguchi
to the I think MoMA to
look at a work there
and said this is what I have in mind
and then he said okay I understand
and I don't think the book that
we were reading [inaudible]
or his biography sort of says
he didn't really want to go
to the museum or he didn't
need to go to the museum
but it just showed me how much
she was involved with this kind
of visual impetus and so on.
In talking about him I really got
a kick out of reading an article
by you where you talked about
the challenges of working
with these Noguchi set pieces
as a dancer and I'd love it
if you would talk to
the audience about that.
>> Janet Eilber: Well it was
a little bit tongue in cheek
but the dancers really have to --
, they have a very intimate
relationship with these sets,
Noguchi designed sets that
are totally practical.
We scramble all over them, we swing
off them, doors open, chairs a spin.
Tonight in Medea you'll see she
climbs inside this beautiful brass
bush of thorns but they don't always
act exactly as you'd like them
to act [laughter] and for
example in Appalachian Spring
because Noguchi used to the angles
of the house to create perspective
and to give such a beautiful
provocative design to the audience
but the rocking chair that the
pioneering woman has to sit on for
so long is about as
big as a bicycle seat,
you know it's almost
two dimensional.
At one point you will see
the four followers sit
on the little bench that's up
against the wall of the house.
Well that bench is only about
four inches wide and it's raked,
it's on an angle so they
really can't even perch on it
so there's all sorts of stories.
In Cave of the Heart, the
big aorta that is at the back
of the center stage has
corners, we call it the elephant
because it looks like an elephant on
the back with his feet sticking up,
and dancers have to step from
corner to corner and not look down
and look very self-assured as
they walk around this thing
and it takes a lot of rehearsal.
There's a little bit of swearing
that goes on I think [laughter].
>> Anne McLean: And I wanted to,
following up on this I wanted
to ask you both about
the experience of working
in the Coolidge Auditorium,
what it's been like for you,
and I was thinking about
Noguchi's comment that he tried
to make our very small stage
which is only 19 feet deep
and 31 feet wide appear larger
than it is and he said I tried
to create a really new theater
with hallucinatory space
so we were all amazed to see how
much you Pontus and you Janet
and your dancers are able
to do with the space.
How has it been for you?
>> Pontus Lidberg: Well we taped
it out in rehearsal studio.
We just arrived yesterday
so I only had an idea.
I had seen pictures and we had taped
out the measurements
so I knew it was small.
I don't think it looks
that small though.
I mean it's small but
it's also the room
or the auditorium itself has angles,
perspective that makes it
look bigger than it is.
And I actually to be honest
I thought that first I need
to create the piece knowing
that it will be here of course
but I don't want to have in my
mind that there will be limits.
Rather I created things and they are
adapted to reality when needed to
but actually not much
needed to be adapted.
>> Janet Eilber: Well we're
adapting entrances and exits
because in the Coolidge there's only
a downstage entrance on each side
and we're used to being able
to exit in four different wings
so you'll see sometimes dancers
sort of running along the side
and then coming in and
we did remove one couple
from the Dark Meadows suite.
There are usually four on stage,
just in one section we went
down to three, so we've been
adjusting for the last few weeks
to make sure no one got kicked
or anything like that [laughter].
>> Anne McLean: I was
amazed to see how completely
at ease they all seemed
on our stage.
That's a tribute to what you've
done to plan and so forth.
>> Janet Eilber: There's also
one thing to note that part
of the Noguchi set for Appalachian
Spring does not fit on this stage.
At the very center of the back
of the stage there is usually
a doorway framed with the beam
of the house coming to it and like
Martha did at the premier that frame
of a doorway is not
present on this stage.
We are actually using the upstage
door that is built into the Coolidge
but that's a historic
adjustment at this point.
>> Anne McLean: Today
somebody mentioned thinking
about Martha Graham and the
library's long connection to her
that today is the 25th anniversary
of her death which I didn't know,
April 1, and we were looking earlier
in the afternoon at some quotes
from her talking about walking
the high wire of circumstance,
practicing living at the
instant for a dancer.
She says at times I fear walking
that tight rope, I fear the venture
into the unknown but that's
part of the act of creating
and the act of performing.
That is what a dancer does
venturing into the unknown.
And I was just wondering this is
maybe a good spot to talk with both
of you about you each have a
troupe, you are responsible
for a big aesthetic vision and
maybe something about the world
of contemporary dance today
and what you see for it
and your hopes and plans.
I know you for example I heard
you had a big film project
with your company coming up.
>> Pontus Lidberg: Well my
company is more realistic
for contemporary times.
What I mean by that is that there
are very few actual institutions
made anymore.
It just doesn't work out that
way rather dance has always been
very fluid.
Dancers have been fluid, ephemeral
and moving around and wanting
to experience different kinds
of choreographers and cities
so that's not new but it's certainly
been solidified that that's kind
of the lifestyle of dancers nowadays
and my company is not
an institution.
We come together when there is
funding and work and projects
and sometimes that's a lot
and sometimes that's a little
and then I also create
works for companies
such as the Martha Graham
Dance Company and many others
and so my time is filled.
Sometimes I'm with my own group
and sometimes I'm with others
and actually that works out
really well for me because I get
so much more information from my
work this way but yes I am working
on another film right
now with my company.
>> Anne McLean: Janet and I talked
a little bit the other night
about the amazing new paths that you
are leading for the Graham Company
and I wanted to ask you to talk
about your expanding access
to audiences through
these innovative ventures.
>> Janet Eilber: Well that kind
of also speaks to what's going
on in the dance world these days,
you know modern dance is
a really young art form.
It's just over 100 years old now
and it was born out of revolt,
each generation rejecting what
had gone before and moving forward
but as we hit our 100th birthday or
so the field itself is looking back
and saying wait a minute
there are things in our past
that we don't want to throw away.
The art form has new classics
and Graham certainly has many
of these classics but the modern
dance has really not focused on how
to keep their classics,
how to celebrate them,
how to keep them relevant, how
to engage audiences with them.
The audiences for modern
dance really have been trained
and the funders to appreciate
the new, it's all about the new
so we've really been experimenting
with how to bring more points
of access for today's audiences
to our classic works everything
from simply spoken
introductions on our programs.
We started by asking well what's
the modern dance equivalent
to a museum's audio tour or to opera
super titles you know how do you
bring context to the classics so
that audiences can enter into them
and appreciate their
[inaudible] and beauty.
So we've done spoken introductions,
we've done contextual programming,
we do season themes like
inner landscape focusing
on the psychological ballets.
We're the first company to
stream a rehearsal live.
We've done online video
competitions.
We partner with all sorts of
different educational institutions
and cultural institutions and our
school has many creative projects
and this has all led us
to commissioning new work
because we believe there's a real
conversation between new work
and the classic works and
we've discovered by having both
on our programs it's really kind
of a one plus one makes three.
The classics bring a
context to the new work
and the new work brings
fresh eyes to the classics
and so that's a very short --
, it's not such a short answer,
but I could be much longer
on that topic I'll tell you.
>> Anne McLean: That's the
exciting thing about tonight.
We'll have this chance to see both
the master works and a new one
and I was thinking
back just to finish
up on your technological innovations
but I was also interested
in your comment about Graham herself
and the company have always been
on the cutting edge and you now have
a new mobile app that's downloadable
if anybody is interested -
>> Janet Eilber: And free, free -
>> Anne McLean: What's
exactly on there?
>> Janet Eilber: Well Google
came to us about a year ago
and said you know we're expanding
our Google Cultural Institute
which you are able to take
virtual tours of museums
on their Cultural Institute
and we're expanding it
into the performing arts and
you were the first dance company
that we have invited to be part
of this so we were delighted
because we have been spending
a lot of time organizing
and digitizing our archives which
are the largest dance archives
for any single living
artist, dance, not living,
sorry any single dance artist
so we were kind of poised
to help share them on the
Google Cultural Institute
and on December 1 they launched
this new part, the performing arts.
We're part of it as well
as the Bolshoi as well
as the Royal Shakespeare
Company, I mean there are a number
of wonderful institutions and if
you go to the Cultural Institute
in search Martha Graham you'll
see our exhibit which is going
to be expanded but it's
a wonderful foundation
about the Martha Graham technique
and Martha Graham herself
and the Martha Graham Dance Company
and you can go to the iTunes store
and download it as an app as well
but there's more information online.
>> Anne McLean: That's so
cool I wish we had an app.
We share some passion for digitizing
our archives and I was going to say
in addition to the Graham
Company we are also very fortunate
in having a vast archive of
Martha Graham works and sketches
and manuscripts and
memorabilia and photographs.
You can look at the
library's website too and look
up Martha Graham Dance Collection
or just the Martha Graham Collection
and you can access these online
too so we are very proud of that
and we're very, very proud of this
collaboration for this celebration.
So now we want to just give you a
chance to ask a couple of questions
and then we'll let them go
back and get ready for tonight.
Does anybody have a question?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Janet Eilber: Can you hear?
He's asking what the difference is
between the Martha Graham
technique and ballet?
You know you've got
two arms, two legs,
how many different
things can you do?
But Martha discovered as she was
searching for a style of movement
that would reveal emotion she
discovered that emotion rides
on the breath when you laugh or when
you sob or when you are nervous,
it changes your breath and she
developed a style of dancing driven
by the torso, her contraction
being the exhale and the coiling
in of the torso and the release
being the inhale and the sending
out of energy and tonight
on stage all of the movement
in the Martha Graham
works are driven
by the torso, the core muscles.
She used this energy to
also leverage herself
against the floor and
to use gravity.
She wanted to show effort.
She wanted to show the human
condition as opposed to ballet
which was very sort of antigravity
and above the ground she went
into the ground and you will see
there's a series of wonderful falls
that she created that are part of
the Graham technique tonight in Cave
of the Heart you'll see Medea as her
heart is breaking just legs opening
and the whole torso drops down
into the floor and then rebounds
and recovers so it's a much more
shall I say gutsy percussive
earthbound technique than ballet.
>> Anne McLean: Anyone else?
[ Inaudible ]
>> One of the films
the library showed
on Saturday was the wonderful
film that WQED in Pittsburgh made
with Martha Graham and I think
an introductory material talked
about the challenge to them
at the time was shooting it
from multiple angles with different
cameras and it dawned on me
that it must have taken multiple
takes and been a real challenge
for the dancers perhaps so
I was wondering since both
of you are working in film if
you could talk a little bit
about that both what it's like
for the dancers to have to go
through the same piece especially
if the cameras could be moving
or shooting them from
different angles?
>> Pontus Lidberg: Well that's
kind of normal for film work.
Either you have a lot of money and
you have and A camera and a B camera
and a C camera and you have
somehow arranged that they are not
in each other's path
so they are not filmed,
that one camera doesn't
film the other camera,
and you try to have few takes
and that's very expensive
but you win time or you usually
have smaller budgets and that's 99%
of the time true and you have
only one crew and one camera
and instead you have to do one
set up and then you have to move
to another one and change the lens
and so on but there's enough rest
in between and it's
not really a problem.
>> Janet Eilber: I don't
know about that [laughter].
I've been in a few dance films
where we did it again and again
and you had to stop and prepare -
>> Pontus Lidberg:
It's certainly tiring.
>> Janet Eilber: the needs
of the costume, it's tiring,
and of course dancers -- , Bob Fosse
said dancers are the last soldiers
of the theater because they
really are disciplined and work
to get something right so we will
do take after take after take.
>> Pontus Lidberg: Yes
but I think what's --
, as long as there's a clear
goal why it's not a problem
and of course you don't destroy
anyone, that's never clever,
but you might have to
work very hard [laughter].
>> I studied with Bill [inaudible]
>> -- microphone.
>> I'm sorry, I studied with
Bill Bales, who was early Graham
and it was very swoopy,
much more lyrical.
I was at the studio
in the 50s and 60s
which had become much more
percussive and angular.
Has the technique itself evolved as
it seemed to do while she was alive?
>> Janet Eilber: Yes and she
lived for such a long time
that she set us a good
example because the physicality
of each generation keeps changing.
It's like the Olympics every
few years people break a record.
The legs go higher, the jumps
go higher, the turns are faster,
the falls you know, and
Martha actually loved that
and would keep incorporating
it into her classroom exercises
and her choreography as
she was creating new work
but also into the classic works.
She didn't expect us to dance
like the casts from 1947 or 1957
or 1967 had danced the works.
She wanted to use our facility
and the effort was she wanted
to maintain the dramatic intent.
She felt that that could happen,
that you could let the legs go
that you could use the facility
of the contemporary dancers and
yet remain true to the message of
the work so that's a lesson I take
from Martha and of course today's
dancers are absolutely astounding.
The job is to use that
in the service
of the dramatic intent of the work.
>> Anne McLean: Anyone else?
I think - oh yeah one there, okay.
>> Hi, I was curious, the dance
that you choreographed did
you have an idea of the dance
and then apply the music to the
dance or did you listen to the music
and then create the
dance from the music?
>> Pontus Lidberg: I listen
to the music first and I work
in many different ways actually.
I work in both of those ways
in combinations of the two
and I didn't decide
which way I would work
because first I did research.
I didn't even choose the music
straight away I had some pieces.
In fact I chose another piece first
that I really wanted to choreograph.
I think it's a beautiful piece
of music, great for dance,
called Serious Song for Strings
but then I had a problem
combining it with something else.
It was such a standalone piece
and as such it was too short
so I changed my mind but I think
one of the challenges of working
with Irving Fein's music
is that it is particular.
There is a lot of music that is
popular among choreographers today
that is more like a
landscape or an ambience
that goes on for a long time.
It's less specific but this music
is very specific and so I found
that it would be difficult for me
to superimpose something on that.
It just didn't work
so then I decided well
in that case I will really work
with the music and listen to it
and choreograph what I hear
and work with it that way so in
that way it's not a conceptual piece
because sometimes I
do conceptual pieces
and then you choose all the
elements that strengthen the concept
but this is not one of them.
This is a musical piece and it's
also the encounter with the dancers
and the encounter with the
music is really the piece.
>> Do you let the dancers
contribute to the choreography?
>> Pontus Lidberg: Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes I can explain that [laughter].
As a young choreographer I was very
interested in creating steps not
to the point of codifying a
technique or anything like that
but I was certainly interested
in this is my step which is
of course not really true
because the patterns that you move
in are conditioned so
they are not mine at all
but anyway I was interested
in making the choices.
This is the step, this is the
phrase, this is the sequence,
these are the angles, this is
the you know all of it and I did
that for quite a long
time to the point
where that wasn't inspiring anymore
but rather I started being more
interested in seeing what can I draw
out of someone else and so then
I kind of just throw a ball
and then see what they do with it
and from then I start like okay
and I saw something in what they did
and I said actually if you just do
with slightly different,
go this way instead,
and that way it's conversational
so I can shape the
choreography with the dancers.
The strange thing is that
the choreography always,
well to this point at least,
turns out instantly recognizable
as my choreography even though I
don't give steps anymore [laughter].
>> Anne McLean: Maybe one
more question, over there.
>> This is wonderful.
I'm learning about Martha Graham's
approach and style to dance.
What else will be demonstrated
about her particular style
in the pieces tonight?
You mentioned a few other things.
>> Anne McLean: What else
will be demonstrated?
>> That's peculiar
to Martha's approach.
>> Janet Eilber: To Martha's
style and her vocabulary?
Well tonight's program actually
the three Graham works give you a
wonderful overview of
several different periods.
You know she lived so long
it's almost like Picasso
and Appalachian Spring of course
is from her Americana period
and Dark Meadow and these dances
are fairly close together.
Appalachian Springs '44,
Dark Meadows '47 and Cave
of the Heart is '46 but Dark Meadow
is very abstract modernist work.
The chorus work is very
geometric and the patterns
that the dancers make on the stage
really harken back to experiments
that she did in the early 1930s
before she started using the Gucci
sets, experimenting with the
geometry of the stage and the lines
of force and drawing inspiration
from Guggenheim Fellowship she had
where she traveled and lived in the
Southwest and visited the rituals
of the Pueblo communities there.
There's a lot of the Southwest
and the Native American ritual
in several of Graham's works
and particularly in Dark Meadow
and then Cave of the
Heart inspired one
of her wonderful Greek
works by Medea.
Again of course she's a modernist so
the thing about Cave of the Heart is
that she distilled the story
into only four characters
to represent this emotional battle
of Medea and Jason the princess
and the chorus so you're
really getting a nice view
of different approaches,
different inspirations for Martha
but I do encourage you
to watch for those torsos
because really everything comes -- ,
even when a Graham dancer lifts his
or her arm it's because the shoulder
blade is dropping down the back
and you are leveraging the power
from the floor to lift that arm.
It's never just a simple arm.
I have to demonstrate one thing.
When a baseball pitcher pitches,
when I watch a baseball
pitcher pitch I see him first go
into big Martha Graham contraction
[laughter], so if home plate is
down there -- , he comes way
back here, his torso is coiled,
it's leveraging off the
mound and he throws the ball
from the center of
the planet, right?
He presses away.
All of the energy goes all the way
through the release of the torso,
the contraction and bam
the ball goes, right?
So a Graham dancer does
not dance like this.
Every movement is coming
from the center of the body
from the floor so look for it.
They're not going to throw a ball
at you but they're throwing energy
in the same way [laughter].
>> Anne McLean: Wonderful,
that's a great way to end.
I think we're about to the point
of going into the concert hall.
Please take a look at
our exhibits by the way.
We have a lot of interesting
material and thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.